Pourquoi n'arrivons-nous parfois pas à fonctionner à notre plein potentiel
en étant sous pression ?
C'est particulièrement ahurissant dans le cas des athlètes
qui passent tant de temps à peaufiner leurs capacités physiques.
Et leur esprit ?
Pas tant que ça.
C'est également vrai en dehors du terrain.
Que nous passions un test ou faisions une présentation,
il est facile de se sentir prêt --
au maximum de son potentiel --
et que l'exécution soit mauvaise quand cela compte le plus.
Il s'avère que nous nous entraînons rarement
dans le genre de conditions dans lesquelles nous serons réellement
et le résultat est que,
quand tous les yeux sont sur nous,
nous torpillons notre performance.
Bien sûr, la question est : pourquoi ?
Mon expérience sur le terrain --
et dans d'autres importantes facettes de ma vie --
m'a vraiment poussée vers le domaine de la science cognitive.
Je voulais savoir comment nous pouvions atteindre notre potentiel illimité.
Je voulais comprendre comment nous pouvions utiliser nos connaissances
sur l'esprit et le cerveau
pour trouver des outils psychologiques
qui nous aideraient à être au meilleur de nos capacités.
Pourquoi cela arrive-t-il ?
Pourquoi n'arrivons-nous parfois pas à fonctionner à notre plein potentiel
en étant sous pression ?
Il n'est pas surprenant d'entendre
que dans des situations stressantes, nous nous inquiétons.
Nous nous inquiétons de la situation,
des conséquences,
de ce que les autres penseront de nous.
Il est cependant surprenant que, souvent, nous nous nuisons
précisément parce que nos inquiétudes nous poussent à trop nous concentrer.
Vous avez bien entendu --
nous prêtons trop attention à ce que nous faisons.
Quand nous nous préoccupons de faire de notre mieux,
nous essayons souvent de contrôler des aspects de ce que nous faisons
qu'il vaut mieux laisser en pilote automatique,
ne pas en avoir conscience,
et le résultat est que nous fichons tout en l'air.
Pensez à une situation où vous dévalez les escaliers.
Et si je vous demandais
de penser à ce que vous faites avec votre genou
pendant ce temps ?
Vous tomberiez probablement tête la première.
Nous, humains, avons une capacité d'attention limitée,
c'est d'ailleurs pour cela
que ce n'est pas une bonne idée de conduire et d'être au téléphone.
Sous pression,
quand nous nous préoccupons de faire de notre mieux,
nous essayons de contrôler des aspects de ce que nous faisons
qui devraient rester en dehors de notre contrôle conscient.
Résultat : nous fichons tout en l'air.
Mon équipe et moi avons étudié ce phénomène d'attention trop importante
et l'appelons la paralysie par analyse.
Pour une étude,
nous avons demandé à des footballeurs universitaires de dribbler
et de prêter attention à un aspect de leur performance
auquel ils ne prêteraient pas attention sinon.
Ils devaient prêter attention
à quel côté du pied était en contact avec le ballon.
Nous avons montré que la performance était plus lente et sujette aux erreurs
quand nous attirions leur attention sur les détails des étapes
de ce qu'ils faisaient.
Sous pression,
nous nous préoccupons souvent de faire de notre mieux
et nous essayons de contrôler ce que nous faisons
pour être au meilleur de nos capacités.
Le résultat est que nous foirons.
Au basket,
le terme « inconscient » est utilisé
pour qualifier un tireur ne pouvant pas louper.
La star des Spurs de San Antonio Tim Duncan a dit :
« Quand vous devez réfléchir, c'est là que vous foirez. »
En danse, le grand chorégraphe George Balanchine
exhortait ses danseurs :
« Ne réfléchissez pas, contentez-vous de faire. »
Sous pression,
quand nous voulons mettre en avant nos atouts,
ironiquement,
nous essayons souvent de contrôler ce que nous faisons
d'une manière qui mène à de moins bonnes performances.
Que faire ?
En sachant que nous avons cette attention hyperactive,
comment nous assurer que nous faisons de notre mieux ?
Cela repose beaucoup sur le cortex préfrontal,
la partie frontale de notre cerveau au-dessus de nos yeux
et en général nous aide à nous concentrer de façon positive.
Il s'attarde souvent sur les mauvaises choses.
Comment le détourner de cela ?
Quelque chose d'aussi simple que chanter une chanson
ou prêter attention à son petit orteil,
ce que les rumeurs disent que le golfeur Jack Nicklaus faisait,
peut nous aider à détourner notre attention de ces fichus détails.
Il est également vrai que s'entraîner dans des conditions
dans lesquelles nous allons être --
réduire l'écart entre l'entraînement et la compétition
peut nous aider à nous habituer
au sentiment d'avoir tous les yeux sur nous.
Cela est également vrai en dehors du terrain.
Que ce soit se préparer pour un examen
ou pour une présentation --
il peut y avoir un peu de pression associée à cela --
(Rires)
s'habituer aux genres de situations dans lesquelles vous serez
compte vraiment.
Quand vous passez un test, fermez le livre,
entraînez-vous à trouver la réponse de mémoire en un temps donné
et pour une présentation,
entraînez-vous devant du monde.
Si vous ne pouvez pas trouver quelqu'un pour écouter,
entraînez-vous devant une caméra ou même devant un miroir.
La capacité à s'habituer à ce que vous ressentirez fera la différence
entre le fait de craquer ou de réussir.
Nous avons des moyens de nous débarrasser de ces fichues inquiétudes
et de ces doutes qui s'immiscent dans des situations stressantes.
Les chercheurs ont montré que noter vos pensées et inquiétudes
avant un événement stressant
peut aider à les sortir de votre tête --
réduisant les probabilités qu'elles surgissent sur le moment.
C'est comme lorsque vous vous réveillez au milieu de la nuit
et vous vous inquiétez de ce que vous avez à faire le lendemain,
vous essayez de réfléchir à tout ce que vous devez effectuer,
vous l'écrivez et vous pouvez retourner dormir.
Tenir un journal ou écrire ces choses-là sur du papier
réduit la probabilité qu'elles surgissent et vous distraient sur le moment.
Le résultat est que vous pouvez faire de votre mieux quand cela importe le plus.
Jusqu'à maintenant,
j'ai parlé de ce qu'il se passait quand nous posions nos propres limites
et donné quelques conseils pour nous aider à être au maximum de notre potentiel.
Mais il faut se souvenir
qu'il n'y a pas que nous, individus,
qui pouvons poser des limites et avoir des performances médiocres,
notre environnement affecte le fait que nous craquions ou réussissions.
Nos parents, nos professeurs, nos coachs, nos patrons influencent tous
le fait que nous puissions mettre en avant nos atouts quand cela importe le plus.
Prenez l'exemple des maths.
Vous avez bien entendu :
les maths.
Beaucoup de gens disent craquer ou être anxieux au sujet des maths,
qu'il s'agisse de passer un examen ou de calculer le pourboire du dîner
pendant que nos amis intelligents nous regardent.
Il est socialement acceptable
de parler du fait de craquer ou d'être médiocre en maths.
Vous n'entendez pas de gens très éduqués parler du fait
ou se vanter du fait qu'ils ne sont pas de bons lecteurs,
mais vous entendez constamment des gens se vanter de ne pas être bons en maths.
Malheureusement,
aux États-Unis, cela a tendance à être plus vrai parmi les filles et femmes
que parmi les garçons et hommes.
Mon équipe de recherche et moi avons essayé de comprendre
d'où venait cette peur des maths
et nous avons regardé l'intérieur du cerveau,
via l'imagerie par résonance magnétique fonctionnelle,
de gens qui sont inquiets au sujet des maths.
Nous avons montré
que la phobie des maths est corrélée à une sensation viscérale concrète
telle que de la douleur,
au sujet de laquelle nous avons le droit de nous inquiéter.
Quand les gens qui sont inquiets au sujet des maths
se préparent à passer un examen de maths --
ils ne le passent pas, ils ne font que s'y préparer --
des zones du cerveau
impliquées dans la réponse neuronale à la douleur sont actives.
Les maths sont vraiment douloureuses
pour certaines personnes.
D'où vient l'anxiété liée aux maths ?
Il s'avère que l'anxiété liée aux maths est contagieuse.
Quand les adultes s'inquiètent au sujet des maths,
les enfants qui les entourent s'inquiètent aussi.
Dès le CP,
quand les enfants sont en classe
avec des enseignants s'inquiétant de leurs propres compétences en maths,
ces enfants apprennent moins au cours de l'année scolaire.
Il s'avère que cela prévaut plus chez les filles que les garçons.
Si jeunes,
les enfants ont tendance à imiter les adultes du même sexe
et, au moins aux États-Unis,
plus de 90% de nos enseignants en école primaire sont des femmes.
Bien sûr, il ne s'agit pas que de ce qu'il se passe en classe.
Les réseaux sociaux jouent également un rôle important.
Il n'y a pas si longtemps,
vous pouviez acheter une Barbie
qui, quand on tirait sur le fil,
disait des choses comme :
« Aurons-nous jamais assez de vêtements ? »
ou « Les maths, c'est difficile ».
Il y a quelques années,
de grands magasins commercialisaient des t-shirts pour nos jeunes filles
qui disaient des choses comme :
« Je suis trop mignonne pour faire des maths »
ou « Je suis trop mignonne pour faire mes devoirs
alors mon frère les fait pour moi ».
N'oublions pas les parents.
Oh, les parents.
Quand les parents s'inquiètent de leurs propres compétences en maths
et aident beaucoup leurs enfants à faire leurs devoirs de maths,
leurs enfants apprennent moins en maths au cours de l'année scolaire.
Comme un parent l'a dit :
« J'évalue les devoirs en maths de mon enfant en CP
selon si c'est un devoir avec un verre ou une soirée avec trois verres. »
(Rires)
Quand les adultes s'inquiètent de leurs compétences en maths,
cela déteint sur leurs enfants
et affecte le fait qu'ils craquent ou réussissent.
Tout comme nous pouvons limiter les autres,
nous pouvons ôter ces limites.
Mon équipe et moi avons montré que
quand nous aidons les parents
à faire des activités de maths amusantes avec leurs enfants --
plutôt que de raconter ou lire une histoire avant de dormir,
ils font des maths,
des histoires marrantes avec des problèmes à faire le soir,
l'attitude des enfants envers les maths s'améliore,
mais leurs performances en maths s'améliorent durant toute l'année.
Notre environnement compte.
De la classe aux parents en passant par les médias,
cela peut vraiment faire la différence entre le fait de craquer ou de réussir.
Passons de mon match de foot au lycée
à ma première année d'université.
J'étais dans la classe de chimie pour ceux ayant une majeure scientifique
et je n'y avais pas ma place.
Même si j'ai révisé pour mon premier examen de milieu de semestre --
je pensais être prête --
je l'ai foiré.
J'ai eu la pire note dans une classe de 400 étudiants.
J'étais convaincue que je n'étudierais pas les sciences,
que je devrais arrêter complètement l'université.
Mais j'ai changé ma façon d'étudier.
Au lieu d'étudier seule,
j'étudiais avec un groupe d'amis
qui, à la fin de chaque session, fermaient leurs livres
et concouraient pour avoir la bonne réponse.
Nous avons appris à nous entraîner sous pression.
Si vous aviez pu regarder mon cerveau durant ce premier examen,
vous auriez probablement vu une réponse neuronale à la douleur
similaire à celles des individus inquiets au sujet des maths.
Elle était probablement également là durant les révisions stressantes.
Mais quand je suis arrivée à l'examen final,
mon esprit était calme
et j'ai eu l'une des notes les plus élevées de la classe.
Il ne s'agissait pas que d'apprendre le contenu ;
il s'agissait d'apprendre à surmonter mes limites quand cela comptait le plus.
Ce qu'il se passe dans notre tête compte vraiment
et, sachant cela,
nous pouvons apprendre à nous préparer et à préparer les autres pour réussir,
pas seulement sur le terrain mais en salle de réunion
et en classe également.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)